[Musique]
vous montrez genre hyper thiery
impressionné le c'est quoi ce truc est
où ma charge et ça pénalise injustement
rencontre pour détendre l'ambiance et
pour les mettre à l'aise là soit pas
chaud musique qui est donc dans
l'épisode 1 c'est un moment extrêmement
important de la saison
c'est le moment où il va découvrir que
cette petite meuf qu'on suit depuis le
début de l'épisode est en fait une
artiste qui a quelque chose à dire
qui s'ignorent peut-être d'ailleurs je
pense que dans cette scène elle découvre
qu'elle est une artiste elle découvre
qu'elle a besoin d'être sur scène quant
à l'arrivée qu'elle voit que ya autant
de personnes autant de gens à qui elle
peut dire elle peut montrer et là c'est
impossible qu'ils ne manquaient pas
quelqu'un qui était chaud pour la
recherche et trucs pense qu'un jour ça
va j'ai assez donné moi c'est bon leurs
femmes
on ne peut pas passer à la presse elle
pense à cet instant est assez constant
la cmq et y aura une deuxième chance
peut-être que la troisième fois ils me
diront pas aller à lille alpha aller
c'est le dernier régime
d'alpha seront peut être que c'est une
drogue ça lui avait tellement manqué
c'est ce qu'elle aime c'est tout ce
qu'elle sait faire les rats peu salubre
eu dans l'intérieur
gaussin morceaux ou vraiment on pourrait
dire que c'est toute la vie et la
présentation de la femme lui début de
son enfance son parcours ses peurs ses
peines à harnes elle commence comme ça
mais je pouvais à chaque fois je me suis
relevé jamais arnaud toujours prête à
gauche et on est un valet c'est un
moment miroir avec ce que atik apache à
faire en saison une au moment où ira
prison pour mineurs dans le studio de
fret de skype et là il fallait aussi que
laetitia nous envoie une grosse
performance est là
là je leur fais un texte qui qui est
normalement met tout le monde d'accord
[Musique]
sans paniquer juste un micro quoi ton
équipe tu publies n'est pas pratiqué me
cherche pas sur wii qui va non pour
retourner la cata qu est page et le bout
à bout d'une ample aux malades tu l'as
pas tant médicales un concert dont la
série non on a le plaisir de découper
qui fait le charme at her d'europe c'est
une bête de rappeuse donc à chaque
moment à ce matin au nigeria
[Musique]
là c'est la première fois que je la
voyais sur scène s'éclater ce envoyer du
lourd
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
je crois que cette saison a de plus que
la première saison c'est qu'elle est
plus sombre beaucoup de gens se sont dit
ça va être une femme l'héroïne ça va
donc être peut-être plus léger alors
qu'en fait les instructions plus dur
j'ai déjà dit que ça m'intéressait pas
mais c'est quoi le problème écoute vous
dire l'europe j'ai déjà donné c'est plus
pour moi le fait d'être femme rappeuse
mais femme maman rappeuse
qu'est ce que ça implique tout ça
quel est son rapport aux hommes on a
fasciné tout de suite
sa façon des de parler de bouger
et moi je te quitte neuf dans la thèse
j'avais plus de familles
et les bas rhinois choisi mans
c'est une femme qui a accepté à un
moment d'être soumise parce qu'elle
pensait que c'était son rôle et que
c'était la seule façon d'exister elle a
rencontré un homme qui la fascine et
qu'elle admire énormément sauf que cette
personne était malveillantes il a menacé
de me tuer si je portais et là commence
à me frapper
le pire c'est que je pense qu'ils
étaient coupables
puis on va voir aussi au final qu'elle
veut pas être retrouvé que elle est
menacée doigts d'une promo libertés
publiques ma carrière tu gâches ma vie
et tu crois que je vais te laisser mon
fils l'alfa est notre héroïne et saïd
taghmaoui qui jouent leur de nasser et
son grand méchant donc c'est le grand
méchant de notre intrigue principale ce
fils de là c'est un très grand
l'islam non correct pas mais jamais les
yeux
je suis hyper content de faire partie de
cette aventure
ça fait tellement vantées pas travailler
en france je suis déclenché alerte
enlèvement toi tu peux trouver la faille
au jeu mais bref dans la tête du petit
jean maigrir
il apporte quelque chose de
d'incontestables en termes de puissance
de jeu
2-2 danger sur le personnage de l'alfa
vous là vous voulez unique et son clip
moi je vais l'unique et sa vie
j'ai repris l'entraînement très
sérieusement par rapport au personnage
ça correspond personnage
tu le côtoies avoir saïd alors qu'il n'a
pas tourné en france depuis très
longtemps alors qu'on est en plein dans
les anniversaires le 25e anniversaire de
la haine
c'est un peu étrange en même temps ça
fait super plaisir parce que de fait
avec des gens qui viennent d'où je viens
et qui est
on est en famille presque
en face d'eux
il a commencé par balayer
et comme la nôtre
[Applaudissements]
donc c'était quand même un kif énorme
d'avoir cette angoisse sur le projet ça
nous permettait aussi de leur grade et
un petit peu cette saison avec des
nouveautés dont il fait partie rendement
j'ai décidé de le ferment un peu en mode
du grand frère et en donner un peu de
force dans le sens où c'est la même
racine là même la même énergie
[Musique]
le personnage de la femme c'est une
guerrière qui sinon tu plus jamais mais
c'est faire pas de concession pas de
prisonniers fait devenir intouchable au
début de la saison elle subit ce qui lui
arrive et il ya un moment donné où
elle subit plus je prends plus les coûts
sans réagir c'est fini tout ça je veux
plus jamais peur de rien c'est mort elle
décide d'arrêter elle décide de 2 se
dévoile et elle elle se rend compte que
ton passé c'est pas elle de le subir
tout seul et que c'est pas de sa faute
[Musique]